vous avez le sentiment ce matin je lui
demande des réponses parce que les gens
sont quand même très inquiet que ce
virus et ses différentes versions sont
en train de bouleverser l'organisation
sociale de la société et pas simplement
en france pas simplement à marseille
chez vous mais en allemagne en italie en
europe
vous avez dit un jour il faudra il fait
j'ai consulté la vidéo que vous avez mis
en ligne r il ya un jour il faudra qu'on
comprenne pourquoi les pays occidentaux
sont plus touchés que les autres pays du
monde
à moi je vous lis dire lire mon livre
pas ses nerfs en soit les crises tous
les mois j'ai déjà vu ce pays se mettre
en transe et l'amérique se mettre en
transe
à propos de charbon il ya 20 ans tout ce
qui se passe à 2 37 petronas donc depuis
le début je me suis dit une chose comme
je continue à penser ce le monde dans
lequel nous ils ont le bourdon il entame
on qualifier c'est un monde qui a peur
et que donc n'importe quel événement est
un monde qui le télé et un instant ti le
terrifie est donc bien sûr c'est le seul
cet épisode virale est un épisode qui
révèle l'état de 2,2 d'affolement fait
de peur de l'autre et ederson exemple
pour terminer didier raoult merci d'être
en direct avec nous prenons par exemple
la modélisation concernant les états
unis
plus de deux cent mille morts certains
dont on considère que à noël on arrivera
à 400 milles c'est plus que la seconde
guerre mondiale donc on peut pas on peut
pas on doit considérer que nous sommes
terrifiés
c'est que c'est terrifiant
non non parce que si les pays qui sont
terrifiés si vous voulez si ça c'est les
nôtres en circulaire ça quand vous êtes
pays si vous ne faites que des bêtises
et c'est ce qui se passe dans les pays
occidentaux où on ne fait que des
bêtises on est à la fin d'un système moi
je l' ai vu de mes yeux sur les camps
devant une maladie vous au lieu de vous
demander comment on va le gérer comment
passer les tests comment rester des
rencontres comment on va trouver les
lits pour le faire vous avez des gens
qui ne pensent qu'à faire des essais
thérapeutiques avec 10 les abbés tiens
vous êtes au goutte à 6